ich habe vor ein paar tagen schon ein
video hochgeladen nämlich auf die
krassesten tik tok videos reagiert habe
[Musik]
doch unter diesem video mal einige leute
hey luca tik tok ist nicht nur voll mit
irgendwelchen quatsch leuten wo man sich
einfach so denkt da konnte ich einfach
direkt auf deren stirn
luca da gibt's auch richtig gute
kreative user und da habe ich mir
gedacht hey da mache ich doch jetzt mal
wieder ein video zur tik tok und
reagiere dort auf ein paar videos von
den besten der jetzt vielleicht nicht
aber von recht guten tik tok tok stig
top videos ok krass wird unter wasser
kann denn den mund aufmachen ist diese
ist ein monster wieso muss denn die
nicht atmen alter also das ist auf jeden
fall crazy meine damen und herren da
haben wir wirklich ein mädel was unter
wasser ist
ja
bei mir wäre das handy wahrscheinlich
wieder kaputt gegangen allein die
tatsache dass dieses mädel nicht nur
unter wasser ist und sich irgendwie
bewegt oder sollen sie machen halt auch
eben mund dabei auf da kommt doch wasser
rein
wie hast du das gemacht hier haben wir
ein video was ein bisschen anders
zugeschnitten ist das seht ihr schon
oben also in dem video glaube ich
irgendwie gerade eine muschel auf
gemacht oder so aber leute wie also ich
meine dass hier wie
hast du das gemacht falls ihr wissen wie
sie das gemacht hat schreibt es mir
gerne und in die kommentare
dann kann ich das für meinen tik tok
account kopieren sluka du hast auch in
the town dialog als ich daher auch ganz
viel
elsa acht hohe einige scheiße in meinen
letzten video was ich zu dick tor
gemacht habe wo ich auf queen stecker
videos reagiert habe da habe ich bei dem
jungen den ich gesehen habe mir gedacht
hey ich mache das ganz einfach mal mit
juden nach hab das ganze nach gemacht
das hat eine junge leute mein tipp topp
video erläutert die hälfte davor das hat
nur 7000 aufrufe hat das 100 millionen
aufrufe bekomme
das soll vor allem richtig scheiße aber
gut
juli und ich werden dann in diesem video
nochmal eins nach stellen also bleibt
traden
das finde ich aber auf jeden fall ultra
heftig also ich denke also etwa ganz
logisch betrachtet muss er hier
eigentlich in green screen sein die hat
wahrscheinlich unten dran in green
screen befestigt sie den hoch und
das verstehe ich nicht
müsste sie eigentlich wieder zu sehen
sein aber ich glaube sogar mit dem video
wird sogar geworben irgendwie bei snap
chat und so wir haben wir wieder eine
tektur compilation die hat einfach 33
millionen aufrufe was geht ab alter er
hat mir gesagt dass es ab diesem
zeitpunkt richtig nass werden soll er
sich einfach mal auf play und wir
schauen uns das an
[Musik]
als kind whatsapp nachricht nebenbei
oder was halte das ja wirklich mega
kraft die haben irgendwie vorher ihre
hände hier gehabt und jetzt packen die
nach und nach ihre hände hier an
[Musik]
okay das krass
wie macht man denn so was da gucke ich
mir meine tik tok sun also dass auf
jeden fall auch richtig heftig ende in
den gleichen video haben wir aber auch
noch etwas meistens drin und zwar soll
das tier bei 638 auch ganz graz sein
also dass hier
ok damit seine arme hoch was schauen wir
selbst passiert
am 1
ich glaube das ganze video einfach
rückwärts aufgenommen singt er auch
nicht oder schon dann hat er sich
einfach nach vorne nach
ich habe keine ahnung aber das ist jetzt
nicht irgendwas was er also kreativ weg
gemacht er würde deshalb eine seiner
ohren ein bisschen bescheuert gewesen
also okay das war schon krass dass wir
sagen ganz gut dann habe ich okay da
muss man ganz ehrlich sagen dass sie
trotz aus weil sich die farbe hier
verändert aber achtet man auf die
hintergrund hier
das fördert die farbe also die haben
einfach irgendein programm also ich
weiss nicht in photoshop geht ich weiß
nicht wie es bei einem video funktionen
wahrscheinlich mit after effects seinem
haben die einfach die farbe von dem
kleid genommen und das quasi ein
transparent
ihr wird also das fand ich jetzt nicht
so krass aber was hier noch ganz gut
sein soll ist dass hier ab minute 917
also dass
[Musik]
okay das war stärker beim fußball so
frühjahr
der ball liegt auf der anderen seite
holte mal eben ja ich mach das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was seine mission
was passiert hier
[Musik]
das denn ich jetzt war da doch noch
stellen
deine lieblingsrapper oder weiß was mir
auffällt
ich glaube ich brauche dich gar nicht
dafür
begleitet wird jetzt war das finale
video
[Musik]
sie haben klauen dass wir sind halt so
videos die ich auch musiker die man gras
fahren zum beispiel der trick erzielen
die ins auto rein und hatte kurze videos
damit hat jetzt die zitrone ist die uns
ja
kurz halt so ein hühnchen außerdem fand
ich als früher einmal richtig krass und
dadurch bin ich irgendwie fand ich die
plattform ganz coolen hat mir auch als
ziel gesetzt auf musik in die vermissten
sachen die es ein bisschen kreativer
sind damals
mittlerweile engagieren menschen
ziemlich abstoßend leute dieses video
heißt best tik tok videos hier sind in
einer neuen compilation freunde
angeblich soll das ab hier ganz krass
einmal ich will hier sind bisher nur
irgendwelche leute am schwimmen aber das
hier
[Musik]
dieses kamera
sieht man richtig krass was das mit dem
pc gemacht das war kennt nämlich immer
gleich von links nach rechts nach unten
das heißt er hat seine kamera in uster
die hingestellt hat sich da so
hingesetzt hat sich dann irgendwie
ausgeschnitten das weg gemacht also wie
ich weiß wie er es gemacht hat aber die
idee dahinter als allerdings soll in
diesem video an dieser stelle noch was
krasses passieren dass das ist krass das
ist das erste mal okay das ist heftig
die anderen sachen auch schon alle krass
aber die konnte man sehr sehr sehr sehr
schnell machen und das hier wirklich
keinen spaß also da sieht man richtig
wie viel arbeit da drinsteckt liegen
klamotten wirklich auf dem boden da
werden verschiedene einzelne bilder
gemacht weswegen die abgesackte
mülltonnen und rammt bei das ist schon
geil
es hat ja sogar messer drin also da
leute dafür
vergebe ich wirklich den willen der
woche die kennt man die online ich
irgendwoher ideen einfach im doppelboden
flügeln gekriegt was ihr auch noch krass
sein soll ist das hat minute 537 also
der ok das geil heißt das ja das hat ihn
irgendwie seinem namen wenn man ihr
müsst euch überlegen die ja
beziehungsweise die macht ja alles zum
takt gleich auch sehr schönes gesicht
hier gerade hat sie sich extra für
dieses tik tok ihre haare gefärbt hat so
ein bisschen hippie mäßig aus über
schauen was der typ immer was okay so
was ist klasse so was freilich wirklich
übertrieben also bei ein paar sachen
frage ich mich wirklich was hier abgeht
das hier ist eine stinknormale
spiegelung und sie wahrscheinlich
zwillinge die irgendwie was machen wenn
man hier allerdings mal ganz zu beginn
schaut sieht man dass das hier
abgeschnitten wurde also sogar so schräg
so ein bisschen das heißt ja die haben
sich einzeln ausgeschnitten und da rein
gesetzt wahrscheinlich da wollen sich
zumindest mal wieder gedanken gemacht
sie haben wir wieder den neue
compilation hier soll das video ab hier
ganz geil sein also ach das ist auch das
mit den händen
wie macht man das denn ist das muss doch
eine app sein als wenn diese idee zwei
leute hatten also finde ich auf jeden
fall krass gemacht mit diesen sachen ich
weiß nicht wie der effekt genau heißt
das video hier soll auch ganz ja das
soll das ist klasse also wirklich so ein
video hier
wahnsinn das ist der grund warum ich
habe mich die installieren würde er
sogar der beat richtig 06 minuten 35
soll hier auch ganz cool sein meinte
schürrle
mal schauen was bei ihr hier abgeht die
haben auf jeden fall alle drei das
gleiche an jetzt
[Musik]
das sind halt sachen die wirklich jeder
kann einfach sich verschiedene sachen
anziehen dann einfach in kraft setzen da
muss man nicht großartig ein programm
kauf oder so ist es einfach kreativ weil
sie immer die gleiche pose haben und
sich immer andere sachen sind aber
irgendwie immer gleich gekleidet sind
ich finde sowas sind die eigentlichen
stars von musical aber ich habe mich
meinte glock
außerdem gehöre ich ja dann
wahrscheinlich auch nicht zu den stars
hier haben wir eine person mit einem
raten das ist ganz einfach ein green
screen da drin daran sieht man aber auch
dass die leute das mit markanten das
versteht
wie macht man das
also das war auf jeden fall
kraft gerade
was diese beiden machen die sache ist
halt wirklich ermessen sehr sehr viele
asiaten in diesen ganzen compilation
videos ich bin jetzt bei der raw datei
bei 40 minuten und ich habe ja bisher
sehr wenig reingeschnitten aber die sind
bisher sind fast alle asiaten kommen tik
tok aus asien
also ich glaube wir können abschließend
sagen dass ihr echt ne menge leute sich
heftig gedanken gemacht haben aber am
krassesten finde ich echt einfach noch
immer wenn leute wie beispielsweise hier
sich das ganze nicht mit einem iphone
einfach aufnehmen oder mit dem handy
sondern wirklich mit einer kamera dann
auf dem pc zu bearbeiten und da halt
richtig so einen kleinen kunstwerk
kreativen kurzfilm raus basteln das ist
das wofür diese plattform stehen sollte
und ich finde nicht für dieses ganze was
viele leute wirklich immer in die
kommentare geschrieben hat unter so
compilation zu jahr da sind nur pädophil
unterwegs alle haben da keine
kreativität und die nehmen wir nur
vorhandene lieder und bleibe ich jeder
tik tok user so wie ich es gibt wirklich
auch gut so schreibt vielleicht mal ein
paar leute auf die ich aber eher tik tok
reagieren sollten in die kommentare dann
werde ich vielleicht im nächsten action
video auf tik tok nicht auf irgendwelche
compilations reagieren sondern auf die
leute itself sage ich mal
ja wenn ich überhaupt noch mal ein tipp
doch video laden soll lasten leiter und
sonst wird das video als auch beenden
folgt mir auch auf tik tok ich heiß da
laser luca das beste auf der welt
[Musik]
zum 1